[Music]
there's been a lot of street art popping
up on the street and we feel that it's
our duty to go out and let people know
the quality of it and we've been on the
street long enough where we feel that
there's some credibility there so we've
got a grading system a b c and of course
f and we're going to go out there and
tell people what we think
is crucial for my happiness a happy
judge
is a lenient judge
borat why are we just writing 10 year
old movie names on the wall now and
calling it a day
so here we have a
actual obey in the flesh separate that's
the studio up there actually we're gonna
make your name off critiquing pop
culture and i mean it was cool like a
decade ago it's cool design super clean
kind of falls back on the whole pretty
girl trope though i like the fact they
threw down and put a work of art on his
studio it's got a really good use of
lines that uh direct your eye to the
face but like again sam said i mean i
think it's now that it became so
popularized i think it's pretty dated
yeah anything that becomes popular start
hating immediately i like the red i like
the bird i like the headdress it's big
you know if you like something that
everybody else likes it means you're
just like everybody else so how can you
be better than everybody else if you
like what everybody else likes that's
true give it an imaginary because you
don't have a ladder let's go
get the [ __ ] straw
[ __ ] come on
there we go thank god
gentlemen i present to you a triptych a
rather famous triptych on the street
known as the high pandas if you look at
just one it's interesting because you
wouldn't know they're high as a whole
the three the three pieces work together
to provide a message that is otherwise
undecipherable the cartoon style that
the artist went for tried to channel
some of the more carefree and fun
feelings out there i just say if you're
gonna put a piece of art on my street
please don't make me uncomfortable every
time i walk by it however the designs
are clean the lines are clean and the
colors are clean i like the use of space
where they're all spread out across the
building for me this is
this is a c-level piece of art wow wow
i like pandas i give it an a
i give it a b
i think it's a b i think it's a b
some might call it harsh but that only
heightens the bar you know
this is nice this is nice because
immediately you can see that this this
wasn't a spray paint based piece of art
a bunch of white wolves attacking one
black dog maybe wolf i don't know is it
a message on racism a message on
acceptance but what do the pink
butterflies mean this painting has a lot
of depth i admire it but you know what
hasn't quite earned an a for me because
honestly the top right corner of this
building heavily underused and the gray
background oh my god nothing's good
enough for you nico trust me this is
going to be the most unique one we see
here some might be more cleanly rendered
some might have cool lasers and
helicopters blowing [ __ ] up but this
one's special i give this one a b-plus
i'd give this an a a all right this is a
big moment
wow our first day
it's a big day for us
[Music]
i'm a big fan of this one this one's
been around for a long time it's been
kept clean so i must say magnificent
renders the human form very hard to do
magnificent renders of the feline form
also very hard to do and quite honestly
magnificent render of battle axe over
there this is a tribute to frank rosetta
well he's known for popularizing the
like this chiseled barbarian amazonian
kind of look this artist clearly looks
up to them drinks are great there's
homages going on not to mention the
sheer scale cleanliness this
presentation top class this is a very
clear a
right here
right there
uh you know hashtag bush did it
hashtag bush did 7-eleven
dump trump
donald trump hashtag anti-trump hashtag
not trump 2016. i see what he's going
for with the puppet master thing at the
top i'm sure the kkk is kind of
representation for just
general radicalism and far right
leanings i think he's just crazy you
know who the real puppet masters are
the insatiable yearning of the masses
for sensation and drama in their daily
lives they are truly the puppet masters
this is a c
i hate to break it to you bren what do
you think i don't like puppets i think
this averages out to a solid sea
i'm trying to figure out
if those were all hand painted there
like all those little ornaments or if
those were like pre-made and then put
put on there you know those look like
brush strokes yeah they look like brush
strokes this is a new piece it's very
new the red color first of all that
stands out and then obviously the huge
man in the middle and then the next
thing that i noticed was the detail on
this circle here as well as the flame
coming out yeah the flame is incredibly
down here this piece is not only
gigantic incredibly well done but it's
also a collaboration between what seems
to be dozens of artists you know you're
dealing with so many different styles
it's a little clashing but from afar it
looks a little chaotic but once you
start looking at each one individually
there's a lot of a lot of promising
artists here yeah this piece has a lot
to give and quite honestly it's probably
my favorite piece in all of los angeles
the amount of detail is incredible the
mixing of different styles is well done
things like taking little tags and like
making spaces for it and packing them
into the overall design like the way
it's incorporated into this piece of art
is amazing not to mention around the
other corner is a whole another side
i give this a rating of battery
aaa
i think the real moral of the story here
is if you're gonna go around and put
paint on somebody's building without the
permission at least put some effort into
it all right thank you there's like
a graffiti smoke simulation this is
great